[Music]
he's enjoying this it is the incremental
comeback of Donald Trump in Ohio to
Violent music he made an announcement
about the announcement it is it seems on
I'm going to be making
a very big announcement
s for 15 at Mar-A-Lago in Palm Beach
Florida
[Applause]
on the eve of the votes the man who
evicted him from the White House
scrolled through his phone as he flew
towards the campaign Trail
if Joe Biden was checking midterm
forecasts it might not have made for
happy reading
because opinion polls across these
United States predict success for his
Republican opponent of the two Chambers
in Congress they are took to take the
House of Representatives the race for
the Senate will be title the power in
America lies where it always does in
your hands the hands of the people the
president closed this campaign as he
began it with a warning of election
denying opponents who would threaten
democracy as the night ended he spoke
results and expectations the Democrats
win the half
I think it's going to be tough I think
we can I think the wind is finished I
think the house is couple
when the ball come we attack on a ball
whoa get him at these elections
Americans will Define the remainder of
the Biden presidency what's important to
you when you make your vote the economy
the high grocery prices we need to do
something about the violence I have five
kids so education definitely
Joe Biden has carried policy
achievements in office and his parties
will be bolstered by a backlash against
new abortion laws
but he's weighed down by a flagging
economy and his own unpopularity a
midterm takedown would mean the hard
yards of government even harder so two
winning party backing for a second run
at the White House
these are the first national elections
since the assault on the capital two
years ago there are real fears of
violence this time particularly around
contested results when the Mist clears
on these midterms it will reveal their
reboot of the seat of power if there is
a republican Red Wave its size will
dictate the scale of change through this
presidency and the next one James
Matthews Sky News in Washington